euh tout tout prochainement dans les
prochains jours ce weekend elle reflète
quoi cette équipe selon vous est-ce que
ça reflète justement l'art de la
formation française selon vous cette
équipe de France talentueuse oui on a
retrouvé en a retrouvé certainement
notre identité qu'on avait perdu il y a
quelques années en essayant de copier un
petit peu ce qui se faisait de mieux
ailleurs on avait un petit peu perdu
notre notre rugby et depuis quelques
quelques mois années on a retrouvé cette
ce qu'on appelle le French flare du jeu
de mouvement du jeu rapide et
c'est intéressant c'est un joueur qui
incarne peut-être ce French fleurs c'est
Antoine Dupont avec sa technique
individuelle alors on est on est loin
des des joueurs de rugby avec un énorme
gabarit qui inflige des gros impacts on
a connu aussi le grand public a connu
Sébastien Chabal là on est sur un profil
tout à fait différent oui oui après
Sébastien Dupont il fait pas 60 kg non
plus Antoine Sébastien
ils ont fusionné voilà un peu moins de
poils
donc Antoine pardon excuse-moi Antoine
Dupont c'est un athlète c'est un athlète
c'est des sportifs de haut niveau donc
ils sont ils sont quand même costauds et
c'est un excellent défenseur c'est un il
pèse beaucoup donc il est très puissant
il est très technique et très puissant
Nicolas mais Xavier quand on voit dans
votre livre justement que aujourd'hui
tout le monde peut jouer au rugby petit
ou gros gabarit finalement quand on voit
que aujourd'hui le meilleur joueur
français c'est Antoine Dupont alors que
il y a plus de 15 ans c'était Sébastien
Chabal avec et en plus dans le jeu
Sébastien Chabal il était connu et
fameux pour ses gros placages et ses
gros impacts aujourd'hui c'est Antoine
Dupont parce que il a ce jeu de passe
rapide il a plus la technique de
l'évitement on voit qu'il y a quand même
une évolution et qui reflète aussi ce
que vous dites dans le livre alors
effectivement après c'est ce qui est
intéressant au rugby c'est tous les
enfants leur place dans un équipe de
rugby il faut des très grandes des tout
petits des qui vont vite dès qu'ils sont
agiles et qui sont puissants il faut
tout tout toute forme de taille de
gabarit et c'est super pour les gamins
parce qu'un gamin à l'école qui a un
petit peu gros dont on va se moquer un
petit peu ça va peut-être être plutôt la
star de l'école de l'équipe de rugby
donc donc ça valorise chaque individu ça
c'est bien après faut faire la
différence entre le rugby pro et le
rugby amateur le rugby amateur ce sont
tous des athlètes de haut niveau on est
dans du sport à très haut niveau le
rugby est donc moi je parle c'est du
rugby de formation d'éducation qui peut
amener à devenir sportif de haut niveau
bien sûr mais où le la taille et le
poids ont beaucoup moins d'importance
voilà vous parlez justement d'une
méthode d'éducation au rugby pour les 5
saisons c'est le pourquoi comment
conséquence en quoi ça consiste cette
méthode et pourquoi en parler justement
dans ce livre pourquoi la mettre en
avant alors c'est valable pour tout quoi
que pour le rugby mais à partir du
moment où on demande un enfant de faire
quelque chose s'il comprend pas pourquoi
il va le faire il va pas forcément bien
le faire il va pas forcément être
impliqué il va pas faire forcément avoir
l'envie et puis et puis faites donc
simplement de comprendre pourquoi on
fait les choses nous permettre de les
faire mieux voilà c'est du bon sens en
fait et alors comment justement on
inclut qu'à ces enfants très jeunes et
bien les positions du placage parce que
c'est facile avoir enfin c'est une
technique individuelle assez poussée
quand même le rugby mais qui est en plus
garantit la sécurité du joueur comment
on fait pour justement et vous
l'expliquer dans dans le livre pour
garantir cette sécurité et cette
technique individuelle assez plus jeune
faut vraiment effectivement donner aux
enfants toute la toute le répertoire de
gestes techniques pour qu'ils puissent
ne pas se mettre en danger travailler en
toute sécurité et c'est peut-être des
couper certains exercices comme on le
faisait pas avant
leur apprendre à se baisser très bas il
suffit peut-être de partir d'une roulade
avant au moment où il se relève ils sont
déjà très bas c'est des des instants t
sur des exercices qui ont pas forcément
de rapport direct de l'extérieur avec le
rugby qui vont amener
qui peuvent amener ce genre de
comportement
par semaine et puis des tournois le
dimanche
le Touch Rugby est de plus en plus
développé et oui
c'est ça
alors ça existe aussi en loisirs vous
pouvez commencer même en adultes en
rugby loisirs c'est plus compliqué pour
les filles en rugby loisir que le Touch
ah bon mais c'est ce qu'on va voir
une dernière question peut-être Nicolas
une dernière question sur vous dites
finalement ce qu'il faut retenir de ce
livre c'est que le rugby c'est l'école
de la vie et que finalement on peut
retranscrire tout ce que vous dites dans
le dans le livre à la vie en général oui
oui c'est vrai que si
on se comportait dans la vie comme sur
un terrain de rugby la société se
porterait beaucoup mieux parce que parce
que sur un terrain de rugby les joueurs
qui sont à côté de nous ils peuvent ils
peuvent pas nous mentir ils peuvent pas
se cacher ils sont obligés d'être là au
soutien ou s'ils sont pas là ça se voit
tout de suite quoi donc on peut pas se
mentir sur un terrain de rugby du coup
ça crée ça crée de la confiance ça crée
de la
voilà le sport est un donne des le goût
de l'effort le donc mélanger le sport le
rugby la vie ça fait c'est la même chose
et pour en savoir plus l'art de la
guerre du rugby donc aux éditions je
disais des trois colonnes et c'est écrit
par vous Xavier Brissard merci d'être
venu en parler en plateau merci à vous